the og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
this is my reaction video to andrew
tate's final message before i do my
reaction to andrew tate's final message
i do want to let you know that this
channel is sponsored by the
cryptocurrency exchange bitmex bimx is a
great place to buy your bitcoin and many
other cryptocurrencies especially in the
world of crypto you need a place that
you can trust so make sure to pick up
some bitcoin i'm gonna leave all the
links for you in the description below
now guys before i jump into this
reaction video please don't forget to
hit the like button and hit subscribe
there's so much false information going
on right now there's a lot of
de-platforming and so i think it's
really important that we get the truth
out there now it's time to react to
andrew tate's final message so i watched
the entire video last night if you
haven't watched it it's about just over
an hour long and he basically goes
through every single thing that he's
been accused of and what his plans are
moving forward what i find hilarious is
basically how we even got to this point
everybody is making a mountain out of a
mohill all andrew tate is trying to do
is inspire young men to be men as he
mentions in his final message his most
viewed video was how to fight depression
he's empowering young men to take
personal responsibility over their
mental health over their physical health
how to become a better man rather than
relying on these major pharmaceutical
companies who simply are just going to
apply men and of course women as well
with just medicines and pills
essentially leaving you like a zombie
now like i said i watched the video from
start to finish and something he really
emphasized is his upbringing and how his
upbringing has essentially given him
this steel iron mindset now the key
point here is that not a lot of people
have been through the same kind of
hardship that andrew t has been through
we live in this snowflake generation
whereby everybody's getting
participation trophies and it's making
everybody soft and so when andrew talks
about these different things in these
harsh realities of life because people
don't share that same iron mindset
because they haven't gone through the
same hardships and so this means when
andrew talks about these harsh realities
of life it's too brutal for them to even
digest their brains can't even process
the kind of reality the harsh realities
that andrew's addressing and as a result
they become emotional they become
triggered they become toxic and they
start creating all these fake narratives
that simply just aren't true for example
one of the things that andrew addresses
in his final message is the fact that
people have cut up clips and manipulated
these clips in order to portray a
completely different narrative why are
they doing this because people literally
are unable to take personal
responsibility it's so easy to rely on
somebody else for your happiness whether
it's relying on them for your pills
relying on the government for money
whatever it is it's always easier to
remove that personal responsibility and
push it onto somebody else like i said
snowflake generation they hate the idea
that he is empowering people to take
personal responsibility because personal
responsibility is hard but once you know
how to take personal responsibility
you've been practicing it and you master
it your life becomes so much more
exquisite and andrew is a perfect
example of that of course a lot of what
he says when i said this before is
hyperbole but ultimately these are harsh
truths that he's talking about that
people need to learn whether it's women
hey don't waste your twenties or whether
it's men nobody's gonna love you
unconditionally other than your mother
whatever it is these are very important
narratives that men and women need to
learn another major theme of andrew's
final message was that he's trying to
figure out a way for him to portray his
message if he does come back to social
media convey it in a way whereby he
can't be taken out of context andrew i
gotta tell you after this video i think
you're gonna struggle to do this as you
mentioned in the video no one is gonna
be 100 in agreement with you ever
there's always going to be somebody that
hates you there's always going to be
somebody that you rub the wrong way
people are still going to do their best
to try and take you down there's always
going to be somebody that's going to cut
up your clips and portray you in a
negative light for example there are
some people that think i'm being paid to
do this video which obviously isn't the
case i honestly think that it's a waste
of time and a waste of energy trying to
figure out a way to please everyone
because if you try to please everyone
you end up pleasing nobody and you end
up doing yourself a massive disrespect
and i also think his message will be
entirely lost now there's a really
important story which i forgot to
mention in my previous video and i'm
going to mention it now when i was out
for dinner with andrew there was a
homeless woman she was begging for money
everybody ignored her andrew didn't
andrew gave her money and i asked him
why did you give her money and he said
he will always give a homeless woman
money but never a homeless man and his
reasoning was a man can do anything to
make money whether it's physical labor
laying bricks whatever it is there's
always something a man can do but as a
woman gets older she becomes more
fragile and she physically can't and so
he'll always help women more than he'll
help men and that is contrary to the
entire narrative that we're hearing
about him on social media right now
another really important point which
andrew actually addresses in his final
message is the viral video of him
whipping and beating that woman he
actually addresses this and he explains
that this was consensual he explains
that it was gameplay and there's
actually several videos of this woman on
many different occasions coming out
saying that it was consensual it was a
joke it's just something that they did
andrew in his final message actually
points to society supposedly being more
inclusive of different people of
different kinks and whatever it is he
makes a really good point i thought
society was trying to be a bit more
inclusive with lgbtq and all that stuff
and society seems to be very inclusive
of drag queen story hour of men walking
half naked where there's children during
gay pride events so it's strange that we
pick and choose what we can be um
inclusive and accepting of in society
that's what andrew addresses and i think
it's a very good point andrew then talks
about wanting to take a break from
social media so to wrap up i think this
would actually be very wise and smart
for andrew to take a break while
everything dies down because right now
emotions are very high we live in a very
emotional society and i think public
consciousness needs a second it needs a
moment to settle down but of course i'm
sure andrew t the top g is gonna make a
major comeback which is all very
exciting and so when he does do his
comeback we will be doing another
interview on this channel so guys don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe so you don't miss the
interview with andrew coming soon
you